you
you
hello and welcome to our monday evening
show help old all you are all right yeah
I'm feeling fine looking forward to some
blitz games let's see i have to say that
my voice is a little bit of i think i've
gotta ask erica cold in the works it's
um it's a little bit of the weather is
not that great in Germany it's like
constantly raining and quite cold it's
not not too nice so game started here we
go FM colleges the opponent what is
going on here do we get no they're
people people don't want of the bank oh
is it really all that terrible for white
it is on deck of it what is he doing III
really that was the most urgent move a 3
and h3 okay um okay I think I tried to
open this up I him he has this wealth
what did i do here okay you would
probably take a plane 95 not the end of
the world but I should have probably
played it probably should have played it
differently hmm this one okay
well there's a request i should play the
semi sloth with black interesting yeah
indeed yeah if i don't have videos on
this it's not something that i had in my
repertoire I ever had in my repertoire
it's a good opening of course and I
always wanted to play it but I always
have problems with some lines and never
got around to do it so he I'm taking go
Bishop b5 let's he prevent him from
castling his position with them in his
position here but the pawn looks good
but not being able to cancel is a
problem for for white ok let's go here
and that I will take quite happily and
now let's see how to do this even f6
comes into consideration just to open it
up but maybe put this here it's on a
safe square and try to get in kind f5
yeah it's X isn't a problem here the
energy is going to go king and it's
going to go clean 2d tool
I had the funny question if people on
the streets of Germany recognize we
execute your personality oh my god
that's funny and now obviously not I'm
sometimes people know me in my in my
hometown where I'm living now from the
newspaper because our our chess club is
usually quite often in the news we have
played a match or something and I'm
quite often in the newspaper with some
with a photo and so on so people
sometimes sometimes if they have some
general interest in the subject and no
leave but it's very rare okay so mmm
he's attacking e7 this is kind of
serious
I wonder if I should just play you 6 and
stop all that stuff looks very lame
really very lame the promise is that
let's do it yeah hello to all of you in
the chat yeah very quite a big crowd of
regulars and good good to know you
around so n what what am i doing to do
ya his king is safe this is not fair
really isn't fair him I thought I would
be better and all of a sudden his king
is completely completely safe I actually
wanted to take c5 but that doesn't work
guys got Bishop before at the end that's
too bad so let's do this the wind gambit
to is too risky for my style and the
Sicilian yes yeah a little bit too risky
it a little bit too unsound but I don't
think it's it's it's certainly a
playable opening in blitz games stop
that terrible but one thing is you
should know it a little bit and I don't
even have a clue right so I tried to
enter here with the Queen I don't know
of it it actually Nets anything maybe
he's perfectly safe probably is that's
disappointing I certainly had a good
position so check he is going Quincy to
I cannot rate cannot treat Queens here
Wow shoot time warning
not good especially not from this
fantastic position at the beginning
they can just teach you five it's
completely enough Chuck yeah that's bad
that's really bad okay black resins the
the starting position here was just
fantastic with them with the black with
white being unable to Castle here white
is basically toasted but I didn't didn't
prove it so let's see if this is bad i
was close to getting to 2400 again but
with games like this you don't get them
um so I've got so many opening requests
can i play the caro-kann or the london
system with wife oh you have an
inspiring opening repertoire the london
system at the car oh yeah i'm waiting
for game at the moment pretty bad him
losing this position as bad while I'm
waiting for the pool attire might as
well go get it yeah I probably shouldn't
have played be six or probably should
have started with this I mean White's
opening here is just not not
particularly greater with to tempe lost
game starting okay I am Pat Bateman so
bad babe modesto suffer that's the only
only way it can be I had a London system
though he for is a non-starter but i'm
currently on practice
one year or so before was automatic
sorry I have to consciously check next
next game that I play the requested
openings I don't mind do that i mean at
least have it something decent i won't
play total nonsense now I will play the
London next game that that's really
that's okay that's an okay opening oh I
can even take her that that's okay and
here i can take d5 there is nothing
particularly wrong with that yeah i'm
born up for basically nothing here so
let's see Pat Bateman that's the guy
from American Psycho right
really hated that book check yeah I'm a
pawn up and have this excellent knight
on d4 playing in a bit of a bit of a
bullet mode here so how to how to do it
it doesn't really do much neither five
so I wanted to trade the night here
night b3 isn't doing all that much no
probably this is not a good idea against
all I guess you cannot get any gambit or
something so 93 now
check 93 is a decent pre-move let's keep
this on a light square so here f5f
actually comes into consideration to put
the night to a form hmm I wonder it's
not necessary
c4 c5 is probably also good it doesn't
do much can bring the night to d6 now he
has to move the King basically night
isn't ok you can play Bishop f3 or
something like that but oh I didn't
didn't consider this one but f fire fry
you
clap 96 on 93 93 probably i'd like to
have 95 available Jack what are my other
hobby is beside of Chester chess is
basically this is my job and I really
don't have other hobbies that would be
of any significance really not I
actually really like to play the game
black resins even in my spare time I
know it sounds a bit wacky but I still
do okay so won that game and I forgot to
get in any opening request hopefully in
the next game actually I'd like to
movies TV series music but it's really
gotten down in time since I've become
doing chest professionally it's um it
was more I spent more time on that
deform okay I've got a game requests out
and
try to get in one of the requested
openings
and now I don't play bridge I don't
really play any other game than chess um
I did play lots of kokum but it's been a
couple of years ah that's someone in the
chat below if he wants to be mentioned
by name but he knows who it is thanks
for the donation so I don't had it on
the list to write a mail to end I can
start address it personally now thanks
for the donation to the channel so
neither three so what was we had to the
color the London system the semi Slav
right there was a rigorous for the semi
sloth let's try I mean don't get share
can do many things also this
you
okay I'll go back you can start c65
against anything that's true nobody can
prevent you from doing that so yeah
someone mentioned that he watched
Apocalypse Now yesterday the the movie
and um yeah yes indeed a brilliant
brilliant film if you look at the 70s
don't you have the feeling that day that
was a fantastic time prom for movies and
from the 70s you have a really excellent
stuff from the Godfather series taxi
driver Apocalypse Now and so on One Flew
Over the Cuckoo's Nest and so on
fantastic i probably forgotten a couple
um and today said what do we have today
like 1,000,000 Marvel movies wow great
yeah this looks a little bit like a
reverse dragon um I think I'm fine him
so let's centralized yes Star Wars I was
more going to the to mention the yeah
like the more art house kind of stuff
but of course I lost there was so 925 I
would like him to take now that he has
played before
now it's a bit awkward for wider he does
not want to what's that let's to go to
d6 a blade runner's game but great but
it's not from the 70s this is why I
didn't mention it it's from 1980 or 1981
I hope you've got alien also from the
70s it's really some cool stuff yeah
there's a blade runner area that's blade
blade runner too right that's funny with
the with them I don't know how old is
Harrison Ford like 75 or something
that's crazy so of7 that's true okay
okay let's cover stuff and threaten only
three a bishop h6 is also it's just
sacrifices it's probably the right right
choice yeah let's let's open this up he
does not allow me to open it up let's
not have um okay let's attack III
hmm game um I'm making no sense it does
make sense really what you do what is
doing okay we should list movies with a
chess game in that please not are there
any maybe maybe From Russia With Love
here James Bond they actually used a
good good game for that so what's going
on here can I somehow break through only
three let's do this not sure if I can
yeah I don't know i don't really
threaten much but at least he cannot
cannot move the rook
loop-de-loop takes me three this kind of
thing would be possible maybe
maybe you can take on you fall or
something ack ack probably can just move
the Queen you know I think I can move
the Queen and they have to a problem
like here this actually opens up the you
file it's probably not so bad for me
Bishop age six maybe
alright you for
oh nana date go see they take c6 I'm
shoot okay just going to try make it big
mess out of it it hope he is not getting
this right Oh keV 6 check is also in
time whining rookie to Mexican doesn't
work f6 check is not winning check
check check it's made check white
resigned whoo Wow it was tough ok so
let's get to the to a new game there was
a tough tactical fighting started Oh
Killy on a plane quite awful on stream
ok hey I place the place this one ok d3
it's ok no I didn't watch the bottom you
William smash someday no time so typical
close Spanish we have nice London sister
I'm sorry it's really it's mm-hmm I mean
I mean autopilot mode the first couple
of moves will it come like yeah sorry
I'm sorry
d 4 is the very ambitious
you
so III you're not quite sure here but i
think this i mean if you want to see the
london system i'm okay with playing it
in general but i'm really sorry i did
not it simply did not think about it
didn't one didn't John win by three
points roughly 55 3 or something like
that right I think it's what I also
would expect roughly so what's going on
here in this game I'm the bishop wants
it too is of course weird the rest is
not so bad
he still has some weak spots there on
the queenside here f4 or trade let's
let's trade this okay not sure about it
so i move the bishop so you're going to
do night be three probably that's the
wrong idea i would like to play 92 here
let's do it Queen d2 it's not a move
would like to play f4 f4 f5 g4 is going
to go h5
let's a bit slow
it's a bit slow smooth but I didn't find
anything that i truly liked this should
be three and then I'm probably dropping
back
the Williams is not a professional
player but neither is John I mean I'm
also not a professional player we all
are teachers basically or let's say
content creators he's so taking ages
here and then he comes up with Rupert e6
so what I do here g4 was my idea then
move the Queen player form probably not
working I don't know check check
very tough position chuck oh wow wow
we'll have to take it check that was
strong very strong the tactical shot all
of a sudden check he probably wants like
maybe before and then some look-see
toward f94 yeah wouldn't mind to play a
match against Evan Williams really not
it has been discussed quite often on
those streams but catches that I really
don't have any time to organize it and
it's a check kind of it's not very high
on my list sorry of things to do
mmm I just got hooks III okay doesn't do
it he's waiting for me I cannot give
this out timeline ok let's a common its
playoff I windows on time let's be more
practical about it check black forfeits
on time okay let's see let's see
yeah yeah mr garcia the shed sex those
matches are nice for the viewers but
they don't pay anything yeah of course
it's completely it's a it just really
for fun game started oh I kill yet again
and h4 really that looks funky
swung I don't know oh did i blundered d5
no but it was close that was close
unfortunately would be aged it's not
possible hit it hit it so here just d4
and and grab see fire from you can take
also but that seems wrong night to be
three coming let's just be quick em I
think he's a little bit yeah let's less
than happy about the unnecessary loss
that he had in the in the game before
which is very understandable so to come
back you can take h5 here
you
hmm let's do this that looks fine that
did there's a question I went for each
they should go to a sexier and not allow
c5 so easily yeah and higher profile
players jumping on the streaming
bandwagon I don't I don't know I have no
idea if you can make it worthwhile um I
don't I didn't look into this all that
much like donation systems for twitch
and and I mean people there are people
are making a living if I understand
correctly out of I don't know streaming
league of legends or any of those games
I don't know if it were possible to get
to get to something that would be
financially feasible taking on the five
twice the problem
it's got really want to come in bit of a
shame here a bit of a shame net screwed
that up
what you said of a final push up age 60
what is he doing a bishop age six maybe
23 takes bishop age 6 problem ah ok so
yeah it doesn't look too great but I'm a
pawn down right I'm a pawn down night a
form yeah whatever it really isn't it's
nice my king position is the biggest
thing here really hate this can actually
hmm and I just take the stuff here if
you killed me then then so be it might
have for probably
95 also could be possible but
it's going to look f6 coming in by now
I'm a pawn up but it probably won't help
and so don't like my king position here
rook e7 problem or this one cannot even
play whoopsie seven here awful
time morning yeah yeah it's not made on
g2 was the thing what I was hoping for
really hate to lose a game ok but I do
black resign against those crap openings
you really want to punish them like
stuff like that it but ok anyway let's
get to the new to the next game yeah I
really don't know if you can do
something substantial on twitch maybe
you can but I never looked into it it
didn't didn't feel I didn't feel like it
would should work but it's it's not like
i did a big case study on on this thing
so let's get a new game going and below
2400 again man
I think there is a Christmas show 20
december 26 is a Christmas and yeah I'm
having a request out but don't get any
any takers and I was like here 95 65
this shouldn't be bad I wonder if I can
punish this somehow it really looks
terrible maybe deform game started Oh
Hagen ah now the London do I have to
[ __ ] game and we'll end up I never get
him with white and now I have to play
the London okay he places [ __ ] be
sick sister that I completely okay
against the London yeah thanks for the
great feedback on my banker repertoire
glad you enjoyed it so no b6 from whole
game this time but i get a reverse stone
wall without the c1 bishop that's a nice
thing to have maybe night before was
possible
so am I getting an attack he will try to
play to play we should be five let's do
something funky if he takes a tick h7
for the check in 24 I don't even know
this is good actually now that I think
of it it's actually rather questionable
but okay
yes ya can play night if FOIA is still
fairly solid here unfortunately g5s good
night f5 wow this sucks not great this
wasn't great as G for business
okay yeah you one step let's do this
make it a bit more difficult to play of
six
so let's trade this yeah probably let's
cover it and listening to music while
playing chess I mean I see that in those
GM blitz Battle of matches that they
played that most players there seemed to
listen to music and i would had totally
suck doing this I cannot do it at all so
I tried to play with night against
bishop him 23 yeah I was thinking about
this but from the 23 sucks let's see
Knight to c3
23 maybe Elway be me maybe age 5 coming
I can go H form 24 Queenie to Queenie to
also here no wait wait wait I can do it
again later however my thought process
here is very weird I wanted to play
Queen age 5 next Queen h5 hmm what is
the drawback of that move can someone
tell me oh great great and so how do i
get rid of that bloody queen here I
guess I don't
I don't say I don't see how I can get
rid of him here probably account it
doesn't want to draw which is probably
understandable certain age 3 now h3 I
didn't see it takes Queen takes h4 lucky
one of those things where you know that
the other guy did not see this
beforehand but it does work
time warning
and that's pretty suction that he had
this check ah come on now I'm missing
this stuff that's not good I could have
I could have just gotten the pawn easily
now I have to do it like this oh man
completely complete necessary to do that
I really hate to lose this game if I do
lose it probably I do that King upon
ending should be should be lost
yeah maybe not maybe not actually there
now you have to treat anyway what are
you thinking about
King g6 King a4 b5 should win I think
maybe I can maybe I can hold it no
that's the clock run down to nothing or
what it tries to figure that our Channel
this ending check check oh no cleans
your phone chat okay check black
forfeits on time not much I can do about
that yeah okay one more game game
started a black game against your cheek
don't master your shake so oh okay the
Scotch gambit yeah this is not good for
white but it is very tricky very tricky
so we'll see if I manage to manage to do
this right
each inks is a g5 that's really strange
stuff yo yo she gives ya he's this car
away night hey hey sorry guys I always
sorry no carro con no soup for you sorry
really is this correct oh jeez I think
g5 is right him this line is super
problematic in blit said is it is just
any problematic it's wrong it's just
completely crazy and he's a really good
really good tactical player so all kinds
of weird stuff can happen maybe I'm
already doing this wrong f or maybe a
forever Knight f6 takes on your 5 takes
on age 5 Wow
my g5 is normal they are not sure if it
is right in this precise position that I
did this wrong I really did and you
never look at those lines you know i
mean it's it's well known to be bad for
white but this is why you never study it
and then you get it in a bloody blitz
game against one grand master of all of
all people ask not against some weak
player that you can maybe outplay over
the board or over the screen let's say
okay but this is still interesting right
it's like kind of interesting i can so
easily or take because of all this all
those pins let's do a county actually 36
it's equal material okay so cheeks it
and it's a techie
okay yeah as active as possible him I
don't want your defending passively it's
got root d6 coming now
I'm not threatening anything is the
problem here Roxy to is not threatening
anything directly
that's empty one is strong
yeah it's probably not right I don't
know I mean you have to play a move at
some point I wonder threatening
chickened out you won that's all the Sun
giving me some attacking ideas against
the king maybe look too far though now I
should have thought about this a little
bit longer wait wait wait wait wait
check check
ok
it's just getting interesting yeah so I
tick with the rook rook tea for you
look 83 route before that's crazy i
cannot protect you form in a good way
try yeah when it's not in trouble time I
think so
check check draw offered game drawn okay
they were a cool cool fighter I always
forget this opening it really is bad for
white it's just what it is but I always
forget how it is done just just look at
this okay I already don't know if it was
g5 or something I don't really remember
yeah this is this is not good yes
stockfish immediately it says I'm in
terrible shape so g5g five is wrong here
but there is this idea really
I have to have to look that up running I
have to look it up ok I think that was a
fun session I'm on exactly 2400 at the
end which is yeah at least something
that I can identify with thanks for
watching guys I'll be back next week bye
bye